[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome everyone,
thank you for joining today.
My name is Stephanie Whitlam,
I am one of the admissions officers at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And I'm excited to be here today and
join the rest of the panelists
in our Webinar on
your journey from Stanford
to the East Coast.
So today we're going to spend probably
the next 50 ish minutes or so
learning a little bit about their
experience, the panelists experience.
From Stanford to the East Coast and
they are here to help answer any
questions you might have as it relates
to even their experience at the GSB.
And what they're pursuing now, and
I do want to take this opportunity
to elaborate on the importance
of our global community.
And that we do have students and alumni,
especially alumni all over the world.
We have over 60 regional clubs and
over 30,000 alumni who live globally.
So it is a broad network but I think
more importantly beyond the numbers,
it's about the tight knit community.
And the deep connections that
those networks provide folks in
various regions all over the world.
So you can see many of
the different interest groups that
we offer our students and
ways in which you can get engaged.
Now I'll take some time
to introduce you to our
panelists who have joined us here today.
And I will ask that at this point
we can all of you who are here,
feel free to unmute yourself and
go on video.
And I think it probably makes the most
sense for us just start in alpha order.
And it looks like Carolyn is still
probably trying to join in unless I don't
have this open enough so
maybe there are more.
Nope, okay, all right, so
we'll start with you JB if you
could just do a brief introduction.
Tell us a little bit about where you
were prior to joining the GSB and
what you've been doing
since you graduated.
>> Okay, yeah, so it's all written down
here but I went to Harvard undergrad,
moved to Los Angeles and worked in
Hollywood but in the television industry.
So the talent at Creative Arts agency, and
then a production company
before joining the GSB.
And then after joining the GSB,
I worked in consulting for
a while at Boston Consulting Group in Los
Angeles before I moved to Philadelphia.
And now I am at Comcast working in
their corporate strategy group.
>> All right.
>> And I'm happy to be here.
>> Thank you for being online today,
we appreciate it, all right and
then Nell thanks for joining us, welcome.
>> Hi, I'm happy to be here, yeah,
so I went to Brown undergrad,
I was a political science major.
I then spent two years working in
ABT consulting firm in Boston,
where I got really interested in consumer
goods and the retail space generally.
Transitioned into a post consulting
role at Ross Dress for less national
offers retailer where I did corporate
strategy for four years before the GSB.
And then while I was at the GSB,
I did my summer internship
at IL MAKIAGE which is luxury
direct to consumer makeup brand.
And I rejoined them when I
graduated this spring, and
I'm now helping do performance marketing.
And building out a performance marketing
team for a new product launch.
>> Great, very exciting,
thanks for joining us as well.
And then finally Sasha,
welcome and thanks for being here,
we want to talk at this
about being alumni.
But clearly, you're still in the roles
of your educational experience, so
I think you'll also have a great
perspective to share with the group.
>> All right, thanks for having me,
I actually started out with Nells' class,
so hey, good to see you again.
I'm graduating class of 2022,
because I am a dual degree with
the Harvard Kennedy School, and so
that means my program is
two degrees in three years.
I went to Carnegie Mellon for
undergrad and
then pursued a career at Goldman Sachs.
Where I worked in investment management,
I helped run a foundations and
endowments team.
And so we invested on behalf
of foundations and endowments.
Because I have two summers,
last summer I worked on my own company.
So I launched a company and part of the
both the Chen program which is an amazing
program that Stanford now offers.
And then this summer I'm doing
venture capital at PayPal ventures.
So happy and then I'm not from
New York I'm from Providence,
Rhode Island but I will be back in New
York Post school and I'm in New York now.
>> Great, wonderful I love that
each of you bring a different
perspective to the room in
terms of your experiences.
And I think that'll be
certainly helpful for
those that are online today
to learn from you all.
So let's first start with
in the case of JB for
example who you have at least been out for
a couple years.
If you could just walk us
through sort of your journey and
exploration in terms of
pursuing a career path.
And maybe talk a little bit more about
how you did land in Philadelphia, and
maybe what resources were available
to you as you were exploring that.
You're on mute, sorry,
happens to the best of us.
>> Exactly, [LAUGH] We use teams here so
I stopped getting used to Zoom.
Yeah, so I guess I'll start with undergrad
and go through that really quickly up
to GSP because I think that's an important
part of this the overall story.
Funny enough, I ended up doing consulting
at the GSP but an undergrad wants to do
consulting or banking and
wanting to follow up my highlight.
Whatever my passion was, and that's what
had me move out to Los Angeles to follow
that Hollywood dream and work in
entertainment and land in television.
And I did that for a number of years, so
a number of tech companies who
are now firmly in the TV space.
Join television, the industry and
was trying to figure out like,
why are they doing this?
Like there's something I don't know
because it doesn't make any sense from my
perspective.
The TV business was changing a lot, so
that was sort of made sense to go to
business school at that time,
knowing I can always go back.
I'm very fortunate to get into Stanford
and we can talk about that too, I'm sure.
But I once I got to Stanford,
I wanted to have flexibility to
figure out things because TV in
LA is such a niche industry.
And that's what had me thinking about
consulting because consulting gives you
flexibility to still figure things out.
And that was very top
of mind gotten to BCG,
was at BCG right out right after
Business School and moved to Los Angeles.
What actually brought me to
Philadelphia was I got married and
we're having a baby and
we want to move back East.
And consulting offers flexibilities and
we could pick any city we wanted
just about as long as a BCG office.
And there happened to be BCG office
in Philadelphia and real estate,
it's very affordable in Philadelphia
especially compared to New York and DC.
So that's what made
Philadelphia made sense and
I knew in the back of my mind
Comcast was in Philadelphia.
And someone would be interested in tech
and maybe want to go back to media or
entertainment.
Comcast owns NBC Universal even less based
in New York, so like Philadelphia sort of
made sense because I still wasn't
completely Be sure what I wanted to do.
Now I'm in corporate strategy at Comcast,
which is sort of very similar to
consulting but do different projects for
NBC, for Comcast Cable, for
Sky, which is based in Europe.
And I'm still very much trying
to figure out what I want to do,
though it's probably going to be
something back in the media space.
So long winded answer, right,
I hope I answered the question then.
>> [LAUGH] Yes there,
thank you very much and
I'm sure folks will have
follow up questions for you.
And, let's see here, Sasha, I wanted to
talk a little bit about your journey and
maybe even how you explored
pursuing a joint or dual degree.
And what your thought process was like for
those who may be considering that.
And also just how you decided between
wanting to pursue both at HKS and the GSB.
>> Sure, initially,
the plan was only to get an MBA.
One of the reasons I wanted to get an MBA
is because I'd been in one company,
in one industry my whole entire career.
And I had a different role
every two years, but so
I knew there was a lot I didn't know.
And Stanford was a great fit for
me in terms of being a playground where I
could kind of explore my
interests with no pressure really,
just explore what would make sense for me.
And so, I went to GSB and
then started to realize I had this
big gap which was the policy side.
And I really enjoyed government, I enjoy
talking about policy, different aspects
of policy when it comes to business, and
so decided to apply to the Kennedy School.
Stanford is phenomenal,
once you get in in terms of
helping you figure out how to do both,
and there's so much flexibility.
And the two have been very complimentary,
I'm very glad I'm doing them,
they're very different degrees but
very much go hand in hand.
>> Thank you, thanks so much for
elaborating a bit, and yes.
Carolyn, hi, welcome,
thanks for joining us.
I had the slide up earlier with
your panelists information, but
if you wouldn't mind taking a moment
to introduce yourself to let us
know a little bit about what you did
pre-GSB and where you're at now and
anything else you'd like to elaborate on,
so welcome.
>> Sure, yeah,
it's great to be with you today.
Sorry for some major technical
difficulties, and I named a name,
to my married name change,
which can cause some confusion.
But I am Carolyn Farley,
I am a partner with Arborview Capital.
We are a growth equity, impact-focused
firm based in Washington, DC.
Before the GSB, I was actually
in South Africa for four years,
also in impact investing but
at an earlier stage.
So I spent two years as an operator
with an education startup,
and then two years in
impact venture capital.
>> Thank you, thanks for being here.
>> Sure, it's a pleasure.
>> So, what we'll do is I see
a couple of questions in the chat.
Now I think this might be one for
you to answer, but
I encourage anyone who has
anything to add to share.
So, June has a question about coming
from a non traditional background.
She's worked as a fashion designer,
here's Apple,
Tommy Hilfiger, and Brooks Brothers.
She wants to learn about what kinds of
opportunities Stanford has to offer
candidates like her or those coming
from a non-traditional background.
Especially, as she's interested in
transitioning into the retailer,
consumer space, and finance.
So, my two especially given your
background, be able to give some
insights and that anyone else that
wants to chime in, feel free to do so.
>> Sure, and I'm getting an Internet
unstable notification, so
please if I break up just
continue on without me.
>> And if that does happen, you're welcome
to take your audio off that has locked so
it might be easier in there,
I'm sorry your video.
>> Yeah.
>> We can just listen to the audio.
>> Yeah, sounds great.
So, yeah, it's funny, I guess, I'm
classified as a non-traditional although
I did have a little bit
of consulting background.
But coming straight from retail, I think,
is slightly a different background
than many other candidates.
I guess a couple of ways
of answering the question.
One is just as someone who didn't come
from a very significant quant background,
there are a lot of resources
early on when you get to the GSB.
Helping you sort of get up to
speed on business basics and
fundamentals to help you
essentially set you up for
better success as you progress
into the interview process.
And if you're doing formalized
recruiting and finance as an example,
that would be really critical.
So, those were, I think just very helpful
in terms of getting up to speed and
getting some business fundamentals
under my belt as I moved along
in the curriculum.
And then in terms of pivoting into sort
of consumer or retail, and I didn't come
at it from a lens of wanting to get
into consumer within the finance space.
But really,
I would say any background I think is,
can bring a lot of value to the industry.
And so, I already came from the retail
space but I spend a lot of my time early
on networking with folks who are the class
ahead of me in the consumer and
retail club.
And honestly, that initial outreach I did
was how I ended up at El Makiage, just
a kind of chance encounter with someone
who interned there at the summer before.
Who ended up becoming sort of a mentor
friend figure to me at the GSB,
was sort of the path that led me into the
conversations that opened up the door for
the internship.
So, I guess, kind of two answers is
basically, there are plenty of resources
for non traditional candidates to get
up to speed on business fundamentals,
not to mention how amazing
the career center is.
Grace, in particular, who kind of
focuses on the retail vertical is
absolutely one of the most well connected
people I've come across at the GSB and
not saying something.
And she just kind of sends you
a litany of different emails and
people that you can reach out
to in the consumer space.
And then on top of that,
I would say the consumer and
retail club is an absolutely
amazing group.
Pretty tight knit group of people because
it's not a huge pathway that folks take at
the GSB.
And so very eager to help and
connect you with people in their network.
So, I'm also happy to answer any specific
questions about consumer retail sort of
offline, if that's helpful.
>> Yeah, thanks.
Now you bring up a good point which
is being able to capitalize and
leverage the resources and
time effort that all of the advisors
that the Career Management Center
offer to students.
So, regardless of whether you plan to
pivot your career after the GSB or
you stay in the same
path that you've been in.
They offer lots of opportunities both from
advising as well as self-directed jobs,
search opportunities, and networking, and
lots of connections, so that's very true.
One question Peter brought
up in the Q&A was,
if the panel could comment on how
the GSB has either helped them hone
in on their career vision and path,
and or broaden their horizons.
Sort of when I hear that I
think of the course that
the Career Management Center
offers on career envisioning.
But I'd love to hear from some of
you if either use those resources or
other things to help you hone in on that.
The session.
>> Yeah, I think I'm still very
much developing my vision,
but I can talk about the broadening
my horizons perspective and
my time at the GSB.
After GSP, even after since
I've left as I'm talking to
classmates have continued to be broadened.
I came to just be knowing I
want to do consulting because I
wanted that flexibility.
So I was pretty tunnel
vision in that sense.
But as I've talked to other classmates
about like what like venture capital and
what like I didn't
exploring what's at GSB.
But now, that I'm working on a structure
looking at my current role as well
it's actually a very,
very cool industry here,
will might actually look for
me and I find it interesting.
And what I've been able to do the GSB
still talked about career advisors,
you get a free coaching session,
or three of them.
So I'm talking to them, I'm talking to
my classmates, developing a prospective.
I don't know if this is
necessarily what I want to do, but
it's definitely like, this could be
an option, and it could make sense for
me and I, again,
still figure out what I want to do.
But it's definitely broadened the horizon,
something that would not have come,
hadn't come to mind, had it been for
the GSB and the community.
>> Yeah,
I think you bring up a good point.
The Career Management Center is not
just a resource to use as a student, but
one that you have for
your lifelong career, and
being able to take advantage
of that is wonderful.
So I'm glad that you've done that.
>> Carolyn, did you want to jump in?
>> Yeah, I'd also be happy to add,
kind of on the theme of career
enhancement and advancement, I guess.
I came into the GSB pretty sure of
what I wanted to do afterwards.
I'd been an operator and
an investor and impact investing and
just knew that I loved that space, but I'd
also been in South Africa for four years.
And so, making the geographic transition
back to the US, and understanding
the landscape of impact investing
across the US was very different.
When I left in the very beginning of 2013,
impact investing was just a much more nice
as an industry and then the years I've
been gone, it had developed significantly.
And so, being able to leverage
the speakers and the professor connections
while I was on campus in order to
meet a ton of different people and
really get a feel for myself for
the landscape of impact investing.
And then, also to be in a cohort of
classmates that are all really purpose
driven, whether that means they're
going to go on to be entrepreneurs or
consultants or investors or
other kinds of operators.
It just meant that I now have,
when I'm looking at new investment
opportunities, this cohort of
people to reach out to rely on for
subject matter expertise for
deal structuring for
a whole variety of support, and
it's really enhanced my career.
>> Thank you, anything else for
now or Sasha that you want to add or
that they kind of touch on that?
>> The one thing I'll add is so
a few things.
A, my husband is also a GSB alarmed,
and we were based in New York,
he moved out to the bay with me for
the two years.
And even then the Career Center
was very helpful in helping him
negotiate his offer, helping him
figure out how to transition as an SO
in his own career, and so
that was amazing to see.
And then, the second thing I'll say is
I came to the GSB not quite knowing
what I would do next.
I ended up in venture capital, which was
the last place I imagined myself being in.
But it actually,
the job came from talking to an alum and
the conversation was more around,
hey, I want to be an operator.
This is what I'm thinking.
And they look at me, and they're like,
hey, you should actually consider venture
capital and I got the job after
a 20-minute conversation.
I kid you not, it was probably the third
conversation I had for recruiting.
And so, in that sense that
people are just very real and
very good at helping you parse
out where you'd be a good fit.
>> It's a great point.
All right, well, let's certainly you've
been able, all of you in one way,
shape or form to broaden your horizons
are leverage the resources available.
Can you talk a little bit about?
Well, let's do this first.
For those of you who have returned, Sasha,
I know you're still
completing your degree but
what will count it and still
returning to the east coast post GSB.
For how many of you was it intentional,
like, or you plan to do it?
So no, yes Sasha.
Okay, JB maybe or for which and who would,
whom was it more serendipitous or
unplanned?
Yeah.
Okay, so for the intentional ones,
was there anything Sasha
now I know JB sort of,
would either of you speak to how
you went about going about that?
Because I think that's one of
the things that many of our prospective
candidates think about is if I land at
the Stanford GSB on the west coast,
am I committed to staying out there?
What's the opportunity to
move to the east coast and
what sort of resources
will be available to me?
So now, do you want to start out,
maybe talk a little bit about that?
I know, [LAUGH] it hasn't been longer for
you either, but
maybe you can speak to that.
>> Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
So I actually don't say hesitant
to accept my GSB offer because
I knew I wanted to, but
I was I knew that I wanted
to end up back in New York.
It's where I'm from, my parents are here.
My family's here,
my significant other is here.
Definitely, I was nervous about
moving across country and
wanting to make sure that I was
leaving open the door to come back.
So when I got to school, I sort of
focus a lot of my networking calls on
alums in the consumer retail space
that were based in New York.
And actually the alum who interviewed
me was in the consumer and
retail space in New York City and
was instrumental in connecting new people.
And being a resource for
me even as I got the GSB which just goes
to show you that I don't know how strong
the connections are within the network
that like the person that interviewed me.
And it was sort of like a stop gates,
and seeing if I even got in,
ended up like really helping me along
the way, which I thought was cool.
And so, when I got to school,
I was actually surprised by how
many of both my classmate of course
above sort of had intentions of
going back to the east coast.
So I didn't feel like I was in a place
where I normally didn't actually
want to stay in the Bay Area.
So, not to say that I sort of focused
only my conversations on those people.
But in terms of networking, I was very
intentional about having coffee chats, and
having conversations with the ones
who were based east coast and
sort of understanding how they did it.
And then, I would say like the job
opportunity was serendipitous and
that it was maybe similar to Sasha.
Like one of the first conversations I
have ended up being checking the boxes on
both functional type of
role that I wanted for
my summer internship experience and
in the geographic area.
And so, I didn't really explore anything
else beyond that, I would say partially
because then COVID happened and getting
a job and a growing startup at that stage.
And the beauty industry was like
not going to happen, I mean,
throw in a lot of people
hiring at that stage.
So, yeah, I would say, so
kind of networking was intentional, and
then I ended up just sort of seizing
an opportunity that came quickly, but
I don't know if it's.
Happenstance or
just my own personal vantage point, but
I definitely do get the sense that
within the recent GSB classes,
they're skewing less towards
West Coast than they have historically.
And I definitely feel in terms
of representation from mine and
Sasha's class, there's so
many more people that are back on the east
coast than I ever would have anticipated.
So, it's not at all
a challenging move to make,
to end up back on the east coast
if that's where you want to be.
>> Sasha, I see you nodding your head.
So anything else you want to add?
And then I'll, I'll go to Carolyn
who has a different experience.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, plus one and
everything Nell said, for me, I was also
more relaxed about it because my husband's
class of 20, I'll call him Evan,
his name is Evan, he's class of 2013.
And so I saw-
>> Yeah, I know Evan, yes, of course.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, so doesn't that work hear,
so many of our close friends or GSB.
So it was never a thing for me to think
that I'd be on the East Coast and
there wouldn't be a lot of alarms just
because I'd seen it on the other side.
>> Gotcha.
All right and then Carolyn for you were
it wasn't necessarily intentional,
more serendipity talk
a little bit about that.
>> Yeah, I'll say in terms of
where some classmates have landed,
especially at this point in time,
if you a few years out not far though,
there's a really strong
cohort in New York.
And there's probably half a dozen
of us in DC that have just from
my class alone that's been a wonderful
community and landing place.
And then the other piece that's been
a really good part of my DC experience
has been, there's an organization
that's called GSB Women's Circles,
and it connects intergenerational
women alumni from GSB and
I think there are nine women in
my circle we meet once a month.
And it's such a wonderful way to stay
connected to the experience that we had on
campus and some of the deeper questions
that we ask ourselves while we're there.
And just I'm having my first child and
in about a month and
we had a baby shower together and
we experience and
support the intergenerational
factor of this circle
has been really a wonderful
part of experience.
>> I'm glad to hear that and
congratulations, JB clapping because we
learned he just welcomed a little girl
into the world in May with your company.
JB, I know Philadelphia,
well you move to either print
the pandemic and then the pandemic happen.
So it's been and you had a baby,
by the way and all of this.
So what have been the outlets of any
that you've used to stay connected or
what kind of advice might you give
individuals who are exploring
other smaller markets on
the East Coast for example?
>> Yeah, I guess the first thing I'll say
is you might be surprised at GSDs I just
remember this people are talking.
The reason I got into Comcast was because
I reached out to someone I looked up I saw
an opening and I was like,
I don't know anyone at Comcast.
Let me look up Comcast [LAUGH] and
like someone popped in and
was like XBCG, XGSB and worked in HR.
So I was like,
I guess I should reach out to this person.
So GSBs are all over the place.
Philly's not the biggest
market in general.
But the reason why we decided to come here
is, I knew there's the flexibility of,
hey, it's a short train wreck in New York.
And that's always the ODC, so
there's always a possibility and
we're not necessarily [LAUGH] stuck in
Philadelphia, if you can't find something.
But to answer the question,
outwards I'm so
connected with everyone from the GSB,
my friends in New York,
and even the ones who
are in San Francisco.
Talking to them very often I think
the pandemic just made this whole digital
[LAUGH] because we're all locked down for
a year it didn't even feel like I was that
different except for the time difference
I didn't really feel like I was in
a different place because everyone
was stuck at home anyway.
So stay connected via Zoom and
everything with them.
And I think doing that and then just
trying to find your community where
you're at because people are there
that a little bit more difficult for
me with the baby and only starting to
get out of the house very recently,
but that's what I'm looking to do now.
>> Yeah, yeah, thank you.
I'm going to go to a question
in the Q&A that Shaykh put in.
As question is one of the main
reasons that GSP appeals to me and
frankly probably many candidates
is its focus on developing leaders
Can you on the panel share what you
felt were the most impactful or
member memorable leadership trainings or
growth opportunities that you've had or
in some cases are having.
So I'd actually love to hear from each
of you because you may have different
experiences or Ways in which you
engaged in the leadership curriculum or
other things on campus.
I guess I'll start with
Sasha your most recent and
still in the thick of a little little.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about that for you?
>> Sure, yes, I am in the thick of it.
So I've completed a year at Stanford, and
I've also completed a year
at the Kennedy Schools.
So I have one more year left, and
this is what they call, my split year.
And the year that I was at Stanford,
three fourths of it was in person.
And I'd say there were a few things
that really stood out for me and
I had nothing to do whether
it was in person or not.
So the first is I
launched Stanford's first
conference on Digital Currencies and
Payments.
And I actually did that with
a professor that's at Stanford,
that's world renowned in the area and
actually wrote about him in my YGSB Essay.
I really, really wanted to work with him.
And not only did I get
the chance to work with him, but
we built something amazing where we
flew in economists from the IMF and
the Bank of England and
it was just really, really incredible.
So that's one.
The second is,
I took a finance class that I loved.
It's called finance school seven.
It's a governance finance class.
And I got to work with that Professor to
revamp the whole curriculum when things
went virtual.
And that was so cool and fun.
Ultimately I think I want to be
a professor at some point in my life.
And that was an amazing experience.
And then the third thing I'll
say is the people and talk.
I did a talk,
right before the end of my first year, and
it was one of the most amazing
experiences I've ever had.
It was an opportunity for
me to show up as my whole self in
a way I hadn't ever before in my life.
And I built really close relationships not
because of that, but in addition to that.
And so
those are probably the three highlights.
>> Even I do that.
Thank you for sharing.
I do wish you the best on your
journey to pursue professorship or
teaching in some way,
shape or form in your career.
I'm going to work reverse chronologically.
So your most recent now I'll
just go to now to see if she has
anything to add as it relates
to that developing leader or
any memorable experience that might
be helpful for folks to hear about.
>> Sure.
I have two kind of quick
ones I can touch on.
One actually was sparked by Sasha
explaining the kind of the conference.
I was one of the Gala CO chairs for
the GSB gives back Gala which is a-
The largest fundraiser and largest event
that the GSB has every year where we raise
money, we raised over $100,000 for
charities.
And put on a massive kind of
like 700 person event which
these days sounds kind of unfathomable
that those actually happened.
But it actually happened right
before everything went for
virtual last year for COVID.
And I sort of with a couple
of other co chairs organized,
and executed the day of
the actual fest event,
and we successfully were able to
raise that money for charities.
And I think just being able to put
on an event like that, I mean,
I've no experience like party planning,
event planning anything like that and
being able to sort of be
a representative of Stanford.
And sort of organize this huge
culminating celebration for
750 people was was awesome and
also very challenging.
I hate sending emails like big blast
emails out to the class and I sent like,
probably 15 that night or
something like that.
So even that was like
a leadership moment for me.
And then I would say,
I'm the second one is just Touchy Feely.
Not necessarily, I would say
seen as like a leadership class.
It's maybe more of like
an interpersonal class.
It's actually called
interpersonal dynamics.
But I was in a T group that was
fully virtual during COVID.
And I just had like an absolutely
unbelievable experience in that setting,
didn't matter that it was virtual.
And my biggest learning was kind of
how I can come across sometimes like
non verbally and
I had no awareness of sort of different
things that I was potentially giving off.
And being able to be in a group of
people that I felt so comfortable with,
who are delivering feedback to
me that I can now action and
now I'm running a team for the first
time and being so much more aware of,
like nonverbal cues I'm giving off.
That was absolutely instrumental to me and
I think will just be
a huge value add as I learned kind of
how to lead a team for the first time.
>> I'm really glad to hear that, I haven't
had an opportunity to connect with
a lot of different students and
see how that experiences been.
So it's nice to hear
that even in a remote or
virtual setting that you still
got the value out of especially
an experience like interpersonal dynamics,
which really focuses so
much on wanting to put your full self
forward and still being able to do that.
For either Carolyn and JB,
do you want to chime in and
share anything from your experience that
might have been the most memorable or
impactful in your leadership journey?
>> Sure, I'm glad Touchy Feely
was touched on [LAUGH]
because that was a one one on my mind.
But I'd also say a couple of others.
So you're going to hear an impact
theme here, but there is an impact
fund that the GSB has which was
a really incredible opportunity to
actually have a pool of capital that
students lead to invest each year.
And it's completely student run as
an organization and the sub teams
have financial inclusion or energy in the
environment are run by students as well.
And so I participated my first
year had a fabulous experience and
decided to be a sector leader, the second
year for energy and the environment.
And then I also took a class that
is taught by Heidi Patel and
Charles E Wald called Investing for Good.
My first year loved it was offered
the opportunity to be a, TA,
a teaching assistant to Heidi and Charles
in my second year, and both allowed
me to meet the Next Generation class that
shared the same interest area that I do.
But also to develop a strong
relationship with both Heidi and
Charles which is wonderful.
And then the last one, there's courses
that are amazing for this as well.
So like Touchy Feely, there's a course
called Managing Difficult Conversations.
And it's all about putting you in
the moment of a case study and
having to play a role of
someone in that case and
how they would have to handle a really
challenging work conversation.
And it gives you the opportunity to
practice those when it's a hypothetical
situation before at some
point in your career,
you will be in that challenging situation
and have to take it on the fly.
>> Yeah, no doubt, no doubt.
Those are great,
great examples and thank you for
reminding me of all the different
ways in which you can get engaged.
JB anything to add?
>> Yeah, that's one thing to add.
So we've talked about the clubs,
you can go into classes you can take,
I was an Arbuckle fellow.
So that means that I took Touchy Feely,
but then you're also in your second
year you're coach to either leadership
labs group, and also I think it
was three first years throughout
the the second and third quarter.
And I will say the learning from
having these real conversations and
trying to coach people in subject
areas that you don't know, like,
whether my coaches says during his own
startup at GSB in his first year and
he's asking me for advice.
And you realize I can't give advice
I just have to help them think
through how to solve problems
because I don't know the answers and
he has, he's going to know
the answers more than I could.
But that was just such a great program.
I'm very fortunate to
have gotten into it and
learning I got from that I've taken it as
like when I became a project leader BCG.
And now in even in my current role is I
have younger people who have I'm working
with and trying to like help
them with their careers and
give them guidance and such.
>> Yeah, the Arbuckle Fellows Program is
wonderful and I know it's very popular and
not everyone can do it.
So I'm glad you had the opportunity
to really get involved in that way.
There's one question that actually,
is this is probably going to go back to
something you said previously Carolyn.
So a comment about your
classmates being purpose driven.
How often do students bring up social
stakeholder impact when discussing
business decisions?
And do these discussions
take place most and
only like social impact classes or
more broadly?
If there's anything you can share there.
>> Yeah, so one of the things that
attracted me the most to Stanford, and
I think this has only become
more true over the years,
was that there are impact oriented
case studies across the curriculum,
even if it's not specifically
an impact class.
So in like one on one
kind of accounting class,
that will be part of the case studies,
which I think is really phenomenal.
So there's a common language
across the student body,
whether that's your focus area or not.
And then when I think about purpose
driven, I just think about how many
different avenues there are to have
purpose in your career these days.
I almost use the impact definition
with air quotes because you can also,
I remember there's a friend I met at
Stanford who went into an operating
role at a big fast Food Chain, trying to
make their supply chain more sustainable.
And that's probably one of the highest
leverage impact roles you can have.
And it's not necessarily
designated as impact.
So I think there are a lot of
people who are asking themselves
these questions of how can I have
more purpose and more impact in my
life in whatever field I go into and
that I found really attractive.
>> Thank you.
Thanks so much, that was helpful.
And this is the part of the session
where people are seeking
advice which I appreciate.
So the question that Christina
poses is knowing what you know now,
would you have done anything differently
in terms of the curriculum or
your experience on campus and
then also how much experience,
Did everyone have before they applied,
so we can talk about that would be
probably years of work experience.
But let's start first with
know who just graduated and
has a few months under her belt.
Knowing what you know now and
looking back what it was there anything
that you might do differently?
>> Yeah, I'm sure there are,
I think one thing is that
is very easy to get sort of
consumed by different
components of school.
And I don't think I was super intentional
in the first quarter of my first year
around, like, how I wanted to be
spending my time and I definitely did.
A lot of brown bag lunches that I had no
interest in, [LAUGH] should not have been
because they're just like nothing
related to what I want to do.
And I think I wish I was a little pickier
about how I was spending my time early on.
And also giving myself the latitude
to do nothing during lunch and
actually just like sit and
breathe for a second.
So that's one thing I think just give
yourself some credit early on that it's
a stressful experience.
And you can kind of give
yourself a little breathing room.
Second is I don't think I took good
enough advantage just over the course of
the two years.
COVID was a big part of it, but
not an excuse of developing close
relationships with professors.
There are a couple that I liked a lot and
we had really good rapport in class.
And I didn't really push myself often to
ask if I could take them to coffee or
just have it more personal
relationship with them.
There were a handful that I did, but
I think I could have probably
leaned into that more.
And I think those are some of the most
valuable relationships that you can forge
at the GSB.
A lot of the lectures,
alumni who have very fascinating stories
to tell you about their GSB experience.
And professors who are just absolutely
experts in the fields that they're
instructing on.
So that's probably one thing
I wish I did differently.
But otherwise, no, I mean, I think those
are, I think I could probably look back at
a million other things and tell you
that I could have done them differently.
But in hindsight, I'm super thrilled
with how the experience went and
sort of proud of the relationships
I was able to forge.
And challenging myself in
like accounting and finance,
which I truly never want to take again.
So, I think other than that,
probably, not a good experience.
>> I want to speak a little bit just
something you said because I've been at
the GSB since 2005 and stepped out for
a little bit when I had my son.
But there was always and
I know many of you are probably familiar
with the acronym FOMO fear of missing out.
But I believe in the most
recent years there's also been
the introduction of JOMA which
is the joy of missing out.
So when you say now for example, you
took the opportunity to just sitting and
enjoy your lunch or be able to say, no
when presented with lots of opportunities.
I think that there's some
permission now given for
both of those to exist at the GSB.
Sorry, I know you're still,
you've had one year you still
have an opportunity to relive
some things in your split year.
Are there anything things that you're more
focused on, especially, as Nell says,
I wish I had been a little
bit more intentional.
But, things in which you're hoping to
take advantage of in your year last year.
>> Yeah, it's kind of cool because I get
to see my friends complete their degree
and then I still have a year left.
And so that's been great, so I get to
learn from people like now I think for
me the intentionality point that
Nel mentioned really hit home.
So when COVID hit, it kind of
forced me to take a step back and
ask myself why I'm doing things.
And I actually stepped down from
leadership positions in a couple of clubs.
And instead decided to
pick three things and
do them really really well
as opposed to 10 things.
And having a my hand and everything and
that's been very helpful for me.
And has also allowed me to deepen
friendships within the kind of the three
things that I chose.
So, I'd say from time when you get
overall just take a step back and
ask yourself why you're
doing what you're doing.
>> Really, good advice for
the two of you have a few years under your
belt JB Carolyn, anything now as
you reflect having been, yeah.
Now that I've been out a few years
some sage advice or wise yeah JB good.
>> [LAUGH] An I am laughing because like
my advice is a little bit counter to what
was just said.
So I was going to say explore is what,
I guess,
it look everyone is your
own individual path.
I was, I came in there with very much
tunnel vision knew I was going to do
consulting.
Once I got the consulting offer decided to
pick classes that I felt would help me for
consulting in the future.
And I wish I had spent more time exploring
just other things that like I wouldn't
have known because I came from such
a nice industry myself in Hollywood.
And they're just different opportunities,
I just never thought about until I ended
up leaving GSB and
talking to other people.
So I guess there's a balance you have
to have of course of exploration but
and intentionality.
It's different for
everyone depends on your circumstances.
But for me, I wish I'd done a little
bit more exploring my time at GSB.
>> That's a great point because
it is something where for
everybody depending on how and
when you're stepping in.
And your stage of your career or
life path you might have certain
goals that you're trying to uncover or
discover, and so on.
Yes, absolutely the GSB has
two years of exploration and
take advantage of that and
also without any type of intentionality.
Sometimes it can be difficult
to figure that out, but
that's also part of the process.
So everyone comes in from
a different vantage point.
Carolyn, anything else?
>> I think when Nel said,
just having downtime for
lunch and
to be able to meet whoever comes by.
And they're like have an open table and
really get to know your classmates
that resonates strongly with me.
A little bit of an out but something I'd
say you should do, there are amazing
crosslisted classes and opportunities
to take classes at other schools.
Whether it's the design school or
the policy Law School like
that was a real plus for me.
And there's just so many, [LAUGH] in some
ways that like opens up the possibilities
even more because now you don't
just have to look at GSB classes.
You can look at all the other schools too,
but it's a really special opportunity.
>> Yeah, that is we didn't really
talk too much about it today, but
that is something to take advantage of
that you're on the Stanford campus.
And that gives you the opportunity
to explore so many things whether
the law school, the engineering school,
the school of medicine.
So the education there are many
ways that you can get involved and
take I believe in it if I'm not mistaken,
it's still somewhat like 12,
applied at any other school
applied to your your degree.
So a lot of students do
take advantage of that.
I know we're coming up on time so
we only have a few more minutes to go.
One of the things that
often comes up is just
advice like last sort of parting words.
And things to think about especially
as Some of these folks consider
applying around when deadline
is coming up in about a month.
So if there's any words of encouragement,
kind of allow you guys to popcorn this.
But if you want to convey any
messages to those who are on today,
what might that be as they think about
taking this next step in their journey?
>> I can jump in just super quickly but
I didn't mention this but
I was actually a real applicant.
And so I would just say the thing I
did differently the second time around
was a lot of self reflection and
being super authentic in my essays.
And I didn't stop for
one second to think about what I
thought any school wanted to hear.
I just like wrote an essay
that was meaningful to me.
So just if you're thinking about what you
should be writing and things like that.
I guess my words of wisdom are just like,
do a lot of soul searching and
come up with something that if you
were to read it to your friends and
family, they would think
this sounds like now.
And I'm like,
honored that I got to be able to write
something that felt like that to me.
>> I would take his good
piece of advice not only
because it starts the journey of self
reflection in the application, but
is also a really big component
of the experience, right?
Your two years and so It sets the stage.
JB.
>> Yeah, I also I will second like second
that I truly believe the only reason
I got into Stanford was because of my
what matters most to me and why so
I spent a lot of time thinking about that.
And we're probably too proud of like
what I put together because I was like,
wow, this really is me.
And so much so that I still look at it.
And as I tried to figure out how to
navigate my career when I actually like,
I wrote about creativity and
I'm like, yeah, well like this piece of
paper that helped me get into Stanford.
I spent a lot of time
thinking about this and
still defines where I want to be and
what I enjoy most when working.
Right I stay authentic to yourself and
I still think like what
other school you do end up in
that school will read that and
get the authentic you and
then you will be at the right place.
>> Yeah, I just want to be clear you
have no idea how you were admitted.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that's always regardless,
it's the type of exercises you said.
And I think it's very important to have
people understand that if you do it well,
regardless of whether you're admitted,
it should be something
that speaks to who you are at the core of
who you are and impacts your decisions.
And I hear it all the time from alums that
they do go back and they read that essay.
And they use it as a benchmark for
trying to guide them in the decisions
they make in their future.
So, nonetheless, it's a good valuable
exercise no matter whether
it got you in or not.
[LAUGH] Sasha, Carolyn,
any last parting thoughts?
>> I'll be happy to add I was on
the like quote unquote older side I
think I had about seven years of
experience when I went to the GSB and
I found that to be the best for me.
I'd had some real world management and
experience of managing teams.
I'd had some tough investment experiences
of relationships with entrepreneurs right
invested in that were challenging and
helping them to navigate their challenges.
And so I felt like I had it buy that point
a better sense of what it was that I
wanted out of the experience.
And to the perspectives We've heard maybe
a bit more reflection on who I was and
where I was coming from.
And I sometimes get that question from
people of like, am I too late to apply?
And I think I had such
a rich experience for
the stage that I was at in my life and
my career.
>> That's great.
It's different for everybody.
right?
Apply when you're ready, but
no one's 100% ready, but
when you're almost there because that's
when you can make the most of it.
>> All right, Sasha, anything?
>> Yeah, so two thoughts.
I echo what Carolyn said.
I have nine years of experience.
And had just gotten married two
months before I started GSB.
So I was planning a wedding and
applying to business school and
completely echo everything she said it
was nice to know yourself a little more.
And then on the reflection point that was
brought up I journaled every single day
for two months to write what
matters most to me and why essay.
And so by the time that essay was written,
it was like, this is who I am as a whole.
And I felt very confident in that, and
to me there was something
nice Like I gave it 100%.
And how it turns out?
It turns out and actually, I was deciding
between job offers not that long ago.
And I call the classmate up and
he was like, hey,
is this align with what you wrote in your,
what matters most to you and
why I say and
I thought that exercise is very helpful.
That is a great point.
Thank you all.
I really appreciate each and
every one of your perspectives today
that it was a great conversation and
for those.
Participants who joined us today,
I hope you found value hearing
from our students and alums.
Thanks again for your time everyone.
Sasha JB, now Carolyn, thanks again,
very appreciated and
have a great afternoon and evening.
[MUSIC]